[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning how's 7 o'clock i should
say i wanted to tell you or ask the
question actually has levelling up been
stopped
in its tracks
we'll speak to leaders in the north who
say they've been betrayed with the
government expecting cancelling some of
its plans for hs2 plus the pm admits
mistakes over the owen patterson affair
mps vote to shake up parliamentary
standards but not everybody is happy
we'll speak to the justice secretary and
boris johnson's deputy of course dominic
raab in just a few moments time also
this morning we're going to be speaking
to the professional fighter encouraging
women to learn self-defense and
[Music]
she's an award-winning artist activist
and mom will chat to paloma faith about
a movement asking moms to be more honest
about childbirth and the journey that
follows it's thursday the 18th of
november
end of the line the government's set to
scrap the eastern leg of hs2 and a new
line linking manchester and leeds
and i'm in bradford which is seen as
having the worst rail connections of any
major uk city local leaders sail they'll
lose out under government plans
i crashed the car into a ditch the pm
admits to his mps he got it wrong on the
owen patterson sleazed saga but publicly
sorry still seems to be the hardest word
returning home the first flight for the
iraqi migrant stranded at the belarus
poland border is expected to leave later
this morning
playing russian roulette another rost
crew member sues alec baldwin and the
film's producers claiming they didn't
follow safety protocols
i'll never forget what happened on the
set of rust that day
i relived the shooting and the sound of
the explosion
from the gun over and over again
jail terms for up to five years for
people who steal dogs because of the
unique distress it causes
where is pong shui growing concern
outside china about the whereabouts of a
tennis player who says she was sexually
assaulted by a senior government
official
[Music]
good morning it's being billed as a
blueprint to deliver faster train
journeys 10 years sooner than planned
the government says its 96 billion pound
integrated rail plan is the largest ever
investment in rail infrastructure but
it's being accused of betraying voters
for as it's set to confirm it's
cancelling the eastern leg of hs2 and a
new leads to manchester line our
business correspondent paul kelso
reports
after covid commuters are coming back to
the trains but in leeds and across the
north of england is the same old service
the government is promising a record
investment in the railways but it won't
be spent on the eastern leg of hs2 from
birmingham to leeds or it seems a new
line from here to manchester
government should do everything they can
to make it happen not to stop
i think it is important that we have
bigger links and faster trains and i
would use the railway more if we did so
it will be an hour and 50 minutes
from lancaster yeah it's not that far
it's not it's really really not that far
i was shocked might need a rethink given
you know what's what the government's
trying to do with the whole leveling up
policy
the government had promised hs2 would
provide high-speed links from london to
birmingham then west to manchester and
east to leeds
but the eastern leg will now not go
ahead with high-speed track running only
as far as the east midlands
and it's expected that plans for a new
line linking leeds and bradford to
manchester will also be scrapped
local leaders and businesses say a new
east-west line is crucial to better
connect the region starting with
bradford the largest city in britain not
on a mainline railway
here's part of the problem with bradford
the train we just arrived on has got to
reverse out to continue its journey and
even though it's only eight miles from
leeds it's still quicker to drive the
hope is that a new line northern
powerhouse rail from leeds to manchester
would better connect the city to the
rest of the north the fear is the
government is about to scrap it
the council leader says aging
infrastructure is holding back the
regional economy london to reading they
can do in 20 minutes it's the same
it's the same distance as between
bradford and manchester which takes
about an hour so we need that level of
connectivity in the north but it is
about the transformational impact of
connecting the great cities of the north
including bradford to each other and the
impacts that has on the city centres and
the towns where they're located
the government says upgrading existing
routes will deliver improved services
sooner than brand new lines commuters
will hope their promise to level up the
north has not been delayed paul kelso
sky news in leeds
becky's in bradford for us this morning
as well as you were hearing there from
paul the only city in the uk not on a
main railway line we know that the prime
minister's been writing in the uh
yorkshire post uh overnight hasn't he um
it doesn't look as though it's going to
go ahead on the uh i always say the
right-hand side of the y
yeah it doesn't and many people here are
really disappointed bradford is where
there should have been a new station on
this line from liverpool to leeds it
doesn't seem that that is going to
happen today as you mentioned bradford
is not well connected as far as rail is
concerned it's not just going further
afield even going to leeds which is just
eight miles away it is quicker to drive
than get the train and that is why many
people do now local leaders here had
hoped that this new line would help
boost the economy not only by bringing
business in but also by retaining young
people comparatively bradford has a very
high number of people under 20 living
here and they'd hoped that this would
give them a reason to stay but be able
to travel away now it doesn't seem that
this line is going to happen we expect
in this announcement today the
government will talk about upgrading the
existing trans-pennine route now as you
mentioned boris johnson has written in
the yorkshire post today and he's talked
about his plans for the north and the
midlands and he said that these plans
will cut journey times in half they will
double capacity they will get done
sooner and also it will be a huge
investment 96 billion this is all part
he says of his level leveling up agenda
however many here do not agree there are
many angry red wall conservative mps
that not only see this as a broken
promise but they also think the north is
missing out again and being underserved
when it comes to rail links not getting
access to trains the same as this as
london and the south east okay becky
thank you very much indeed thanks a lot
let's speak to former chair of the east
midlands hst programme board and that's
john collins hello to you mr collins
thank you for joining us what on earth
is going on
well i think um we've been aware that
this is a conversation that's been
adding government for some time and what
i would say though is
it's the same old story for the east
midlands um electrification of middle
and mainline uh proposed by a labor
government
off with the conservative government on
again just before an election off again
just after the election
this is a commitment that was given by
the prime minister that the the eastern
leg of hs2 was going to happen now it's
not going to happen and that's going to
cause very significant i think economic
harm to this part of the country
i wanted to ask you about that whether
it's um you know what what is the point
of the why at the right hand why of of
hs2 is it faster lane faster trains to
london or is it to improve the economy
of the region
well it should be about improving the
economy um from the midlands north the
reality is that london overheats
economically whereas looking north
there's there's capacity for growth
and investment and
that's what hs2 was supposed to be about
it was supposed to be about looking
north
and creating growth and opportunities
leveling up effectively and
once you remove
that fast link that link between
birmingham and nottingham and sheffield
and leeds and in and in the same sense
as well a fast route even
through the y back up to manchester um
you're actually losing a lot of that
economic benefit so we're not going to
get the growth and opportunity that we
otherwise would have
the government will say in response that
they're
investing 96 billion pounds in rail
projects
and
we'll see the details of that today um
all i would say on that is if you invest
in the existing network um what you're
gonna you're not gonna increase the
capacity um anywhere near as much as you
are if you're gonna build new routes and
of course when you are improving the
existing network i i think commuters
know of all of the um all of the
disruption and aggravation that comes
with major works on existing railway
lines build a new line um the existing
line of the existing network gets to
operate as it currently operates um and
just as the construction work is
happening if you try and conflate the
two then that's going to cause
incredible damage
when you talk about capacity of from
what you're saying are you talking about
more people being able to use these
lines as opposed to them being faster
well i think
what hs2 offered was both more people
being able to to travel
and to travel into city which is really
important but equally um that freeing up
capacity on the existing network not
just for passengers but also for freight
and
we're looking at lines that are under
very significant pressure um and that
pressure isn't going to be eased simply
by
looking to improve and upgrade the
existing lines
how surprised are you to find
the situation as it is this morning that
the
right hand side of the y is not going to
go ahead
i'm not that surprised to be honest um
it's it's very clear that the east
midlands misses out because
the west
the western leg
has a very effective metro mayor in
manchester um arguing the case a very
effective metro mayor in birmingham
arguing the case we tried to work on
that as a proposal for the east midlands
but it didn't happen some four to five
years ago and i think we've been losing
out um ever since but the real
uh damage that will be done to the east
midlands and the uh eastern side of
england with the eastern leg not going
ahead is is that if the western leg goes
ahead as is proposed here what you're
going to see is you're going to see the
investment and the opportunity that
would have gone um to
nottingham to sheffield to leeds to the
communities in between effectively being
sucked across to the western side of the
country sucked across to the west and
also sucked back down to london
and that was that was the problem that
hs2 had the potential to tackle
what would you say i mean the prime
minister is very well aware of how long
it takes to travel around the country on
trains having done it when he went up to
um cop 26 in glasgow at the end of last
week what's your message to him this
morning
i think my message to him would be to do
a u-turn on this um we've seen a u-turn
on on frankly a lot a lot less important
issues
and i think that
this is about shaping the whole future
of
the economy of our country
and i think it would be uh a one-time
major strategic mistake um not to go
ahead with the eastern leg of hs2
mr collins thank you for joining us
thank you
thank you
we'll be hearing from the deputy prime
minister in just a few minutes time of
course we'll be asking him about hs2 and
where we go from here meantime the first
flight of
migrants stranded at poland's border
with belarus is expected to leave for
iraq this morning hundreds of refugees
who've been camped at the border in
freezing conditions have been moved to a
nearby warehouse in belarus but many
more are trying to find other ways of
crossing into the eu fearing being sent
back to the countries from which they
came
the actor alec baldwin has been accused
of playing russian roulette on the set
of the movie rost where he accidentally
shot dead the film's cinematographer
script supervisor mummy mitchell is the
latest crew member to take legal action
against him and the film's other
producers she was the first person on
set to dial emergency services
i'll never forget what happened on the
set of rust that day
i relived the shooting and the sound of
the explosion
from the gun over and over again
i'm depressed i don't feel safe i feel
like at any moment anything could happen
to me
and to those that i care about that are
standing close to me
germany is considering fresh measures to
tackle a surge in covet 19 cases the
country has reported more than 65 000
cases in the last 24-hour period the
three political parties negotiating to
form germany's next government have
agreed on a series of public health
measures for parliament to debate they
include stricter workplace rules and
sharply increasing the penalties for
forging vaccine or test certificates
the nhs has been approved to offer hiv
sufferers the first long-acting
injection to treat the virus it's
estimated around 13 000 people will now
be eligible for the treatment in england
eliminating the need to ingest daily
anti-retroviral drugs
now people convicted of stealing dogs
could be jailed for up to five years
under new government plans let's find
out more about it shingi is standing by
for us in old deer park in richmond in
south west london this morning hello to
you good morning quite right too that's
what i say shingi good morning good
morning
good morning yeah it's a good day to be
a dog owner campaigners have been
calling for this for quite some time now
calls that grew louder during lockdown
with the increased cases in dog thefts
according to defra figures there were
more than two thousand animals lost last
year seven in ten of those were dogs and
the government in response to that set
up a task force a pet theft task force
and they've come up with this
legislation which doesn't just jail
people convicted of stealing dogs for
five years but it also treats dogs
rather than property but ascent sentient
beings you know the the friendly people
the friendly four-legged friends we have
at home that's what the legislation does
and judges will take into account things
like emotional distress calls to both
the dog and the owner when handing out a
sentence it's important legislation
because it could set and train some
other legislation as well so defra are
saying this morning that there could
also be similar legislation forever
other pets meaning that the distress
caused by losing their animals
which has happened to thousands of
people in last year could could slow
down and there could be you know there
could be greater greater penalties and
greater punishments for people who are
stealing animals
okay for now thank you thanks a lot
good
still to come on the program just after
half past we'll get the chair of the
common standards committee that's chris
brides his take on boris johnson's
efforts to deal with sleaze in his party
and a feisty day in the commons
today marks a day when women effectively
start to work for free for the rest of
the year because they earn less money
than men we'll speak to the women's
equality party at twenty to eight
and the coveted situation remains
critical in wales we'll ask the nation's
health minister if there are plans for
any further restrictions as just after a
quarter two
lady gaga says she drew on the dark side
of her own past to play patricia
reggiani who was found guilty of hiring
a hitman to assassinate her husband in
1998.
gaga stars as patricia in uh house of
gucci a film based on the true story of
the family family run i should say gucci
fashion empire directed by ridley scott
our arts and entertainment correspondent
katie spencer reports
i don't consider myself a particularly
ethical person no but i am fair
based on the true story of the
family-run gucci fashion empire lady
gaga's new role sees her play patricia
reggiani who in 1998 was found guilty of
hiring a hitman to carry out the
cold-blooded assassination of her
husband
[Laughter]
to say that the guccis were complicated
would be a massive understatement
what was fascinating to me was that i
didn't actually believe ever that
patricia gucci was a gold digger just
because this woman was lower class than
the gucci's and wanted better for
herself it doesn't make her a hustler in
a negative way there's this illusion of
power that like you said in a
patriarchal society and in this
patriarchal system was actually just a
total illusion because as soon as they
said this is not a girl's game patrizia
her whole house of cards begins to fall
we can't justify what she did though
it's reprehensible it's horrible and
when this murder took place i believe it
happened because she was so traumatized
so hurt that she made a terrible
awful mistake
that she deeply regrets
gaga's music outfits might speak to a
vivid imagination but the singer who has
spoken about being raped by a male music
producer when she was 19 says she drew
on the darker side of her life to make
her character feel real
when i think about my real life
experiences there was a lot of things
that i've been through in my life
traumatic experiences that i drew upon
to play patrizia and
it's not necessarily imaginative i guess
in that way meaning i'm i'm calling upon
myself
uh now it might be imaginative to you
you might see it and say oh that that
that looks like it possesses imagination
but for me it's it's not imaginative
it's real and it's emotional because i'm
an italian-american woman and my
family's from italy and my family worked
so hard on the soil that we filmed this
movie on
so that i could have a better life and
here i am talking to you about starring
in a ridley scott film
this is a real honor and i'm really
grateful
gaga's eccentricities might make her the
focus of fascination in real life but
strip away the costumes and wigs and to
her latest role on screen she brings a
gripping intensity katy spencer sky news
follow that except with this the deputy
prime minister is with us now good
morning thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning uh let's start
with slee should we why not on a clear
road i crashed a car into a ditch is
what the prime minister has said how
damaging is this whole business for you
i think what the public expects us to
fix the problem what the pm has said is
that yes there's been a mistake made
we regret that but now we're fixing it
and last night we voted in the house of
commons on a government
resolution which does two things one it
stops people acting as paid lobbyists or
consultants in relation to political
work i think that's critically important
for public confidence secondly in terms
of the broader question we've uh asked
the committee on standards to work up
the detail but around the principle that
your overriding priority must be serving
your constituents and therefore there
must be limits on external interests the
committee on standards will work that up
by january so it's not something that's
being put into the long grass so we're
tackling and fixing the problem at hand
okay um 297 to nil is how that went
through that vote yesterday where was
everybody else
the most important thing is it went
through overwhelmingly so um we can now
deal with the problem but a lot of tory
back benches are showing their true
feelings by not turning up to vote well
i think there's probably other people
that
thought that actually these were common
sense proposals very happy for them to
go through uh it was a late late-ish
vote um
i think it was around seven o'clock bit
later than that but look i can't account
for uh every member of parliament on on
either side i was there i voted i wanted
to vote uh because i think it's
important you accept though that there
is unrest amongst the party i mean the
prime minister went to and meet a series
of mps last night as he walked into the
room it was apparently um completely
silent you'll always hear one or other
disgruntled individual anonymously in
the media on whichever side of a debate
my sense is overwhelmingly uh mps want
us to fix the problem we've done that
move on and start talking about the
things that voters really care about
like the transport the infrastructure
the rail announcement we've made today i
i'm very happy to answer the questions
but actually if you are talk to mps let
alone voters they want us focused on
their issues the quality of life issues
that matter to them they want this
resolved we've resolved it we're now
talking about rail today uh i'll come on
to that interview no no sure i'm just
saying if if my the feedback mps give me
is they want the government the same as
our constituents on the job of fixing
the problems that matter them in their
daily lives so there's no unrest at all
as far as the prime minister is
concerned all the backbenchers are
completely happy with him i'm not sure
but it quite an idyllic way how would
you put it i'd say look there's always a
debate uh
amongst mps but the most important thing
and the overwhelming response i've seen
is we're fixing the problem that's a
positive step forward we can get on with
the business
and the job of bouncing back from this
recovery stronger cleaner
and dealing with things like
connectivity for northern cities cost of
living and all those other issues that
our voters care about okay let's talk
about what's happening with hs2 should
we the eastern leg of hs2 the prime
minister's written in the yorkshire post
basically saying that it's not going to
go ahead i mean why not
look first of all the details of the
different legs will be announced later
on today in the house of commons i think
that's the right thing to do given the
commercial sensitivity i can tell you
though 96 billion pounds going into
infrastructure rail infrastructure to
link uh the rest of the country with the
midlands and the north and critically
the configuration of the projects will
mean we can deliver those uh rail links
much quicker and they will focus not
just on linking the south london with
the midlands and the north but also the
interconnectivity between those regions
when you talk to small and medium-sized
businesses in those regions that is
critical for them because a lot of their
market thrives and the opportunities are
about that regional interconnectivity
and that's what 96 billion pounds of
investment is going to deliver 56
billion which is already promised as
part of hs2 we were speaking to the chap
earlier who was responsible for the
eastern leg previously he says that the
government should think again it's
absolutely the wrong thing to do well as
i've explained the rationale for what
we're doing it's about speed of delivery
it's about the interconnectivity not
just between the south london the
midlands and the north but between the
towns and the cities of the north i'm
not going to as i said for commercial
sensitivity reasons comment on
individual legs we will here of the hs2
route we'll hear the full detail uh
later in the house of commons okay if
it's all about connectivity in the
region why not do the same on the
western leg of the hs2 line well i think
we're looking at the
uh where you get best value for
taxpayers money where the infrastructure
will deliver the best yield economically
in terms of growth and for the
businesses that are already there who've
got the scope for expansion and for for
growing particularly you think about
small or medium-sized businesses that
can scale up what really will matter to
them what will really add value to them
and i know that the transport sector and
the chancellor been very focused on
delivering the best bang for the buck
for those businesses and for the
regional economy uh in the north in the
midlands and that's where it's focused
is it not uh deputy prime minister the
fact that uh the metro mayors on the
west of the country are more vocal and
as a result you thought okay let's just
keep that one and forget about that
no but what we do want is active and
strong leadership from the metro mayors
from the local authorities who working
as a team
with central government and the
communities they serve can get the best
value economic value value for taxpayers
money out of these projects and of
course we do consult with the local
leaders around the country that's that's
that's right that's what local democracy
is all about what about the northern
powerhouse rail line that goes um across
the pennines
why why are you scrapping that it was in
the manifesto well look uh in terms of
the detail of individual legs as i said
uh that will all be announced in the
house of commons it's right to do that
you've been talking about sleeves we
want the respect the prime minister
wrote in the yorkshire post well we want
to respect in terms of beyond what
what's already been said we want to
respect the rules on commercial
sensitivity but what i can tell you in
terms of interconnectivity which is the
underlying point this is the 96 billion
pounds can be absolutely focused not
just on the national links but the
regional links the interconnectivity
where it adds the most value so given
that you did it was um a promise in the
manifesto that there would be uh across
pennine uh link that will continue
you'll need to wait as uh i said earlier
for the full details uh of the projects
and the links and the regional links and
the limbs of hs2 and the other projects
uh a little longer but it will be out
today in the house of commons you're not
going to have to wait long yeah what
about the people in bradford it's the
seventh biggest city um in the country
it's the only city the big city that
isn't on a main rail line and we were
speaking to somebody from bradford
earlier they say it's quicker it was
quicker by steam train than it is now
right um
again we're very focused on bradford
they uh
very important part of the country but
the specific projects the specific limbs
i've got to allow um the the prime
minister and the transport secretary to
set out the detail of that as a in the
way i described yeah the concern is that
leveling up is just a catchy phrase and
actually when it comes to it that this
conservative party this government is
not leveling up by any measure 96
billion pounds over 50 odd billion
that's already been promised well sure
but we're delivering the projects we're
setting out with a uh
as expedited a time frame as we can i
don't think anyone can reasonably
say that 96 billion pounds isn't a what
about people
on the main rail line i don't think
there has ever been a rail investment
project
on the scale of what this government is
doing i think anyone that is i mean you
people can quibble about individual
lines of course uh and that's the
scrutiny and there's always more demand
than there is uh supply with these
things but but 96 billion pounds it's a
step change it will deliver the leveling
up and by the way that's good for the
whole country it'll be good for the
midlands will be good for the north more
jobs
more tax revenue coming out of those
polls of economic activity be good for
the rest of the country to have a more
balanced economy it's good for
constituencies like mine because it'll
mean less pressure on housing
more tax revenue generated more broadly
i think it's good for the whole country
let's talk about migrants um should we
i'm reading in the times this morning
that apparently we're going to gather
them up put them on planes
and send them to albania what a great
idea obviously not well look we've seen
uh 19 000
crossings stopped this year alone 65
convictions secured the criminal the
predatory criminal gangs that thrive on
this miserable trade and the home
secretary has been engaged with her
opposite number in france
this week their determination is to
eliminate all of these illegal crossings
i think it's right there's practice
around the world in relation to this to
look at least the possibilities of
international partnerships for
international processing of some of
these claims they're not going to
albania though aren't they come on well
that's one country but we've i mean as
foreign secretary we are willing uh to
look with partners at whether it's
possible to do this international
processing the point is as well as
focusing on
regional processing which is probably
the most the best way the optimum way to
dealing with refugees close to source as
possible better for them but also we
want to look with international partners
at how we reduce the pull factor so that
is the incentives for the criminal gangs
to try and bring people from these
war-torn zones or these poorer parts of
the world to the uk we must reduce the
pull factor we'll look at all of the
legitimate means of doing that and we'll
do so with our with our partners and
allies i think i'm right in saying that
only five people have been uh sent back
home having come to the uk um illegally
this year the um home secretary who you
quoted there on a plane said the system
is broken
you guys have been in power for 11 years
well look and we've uh taken steps but
the demand and the pressures have
increased the two things that we're
doing we
pretty patel is looking at the signing
system she's got a plan to fix it we've
got a borders bill
that is going to be going through
parliament i'm also looking at the
related underlying issues around human
rights we're going to be putting forward
proposals for consultation in relation
to that and we know we've got a big
problem particularly with foreign
national offenders and that is separate
i don't want to conflate the issue of
asylum with that but we know we have a
problem with returning people to
countries because of the expansion of
human rights so we will deal with both
of those issues the immigration and
border system but also the underlying
human rights framework but it was
incorrect wasn't it to suggest that um
all asylum seekers or the inference was
that asylum seekers are potential
terrorists that's what basically the
home secretary was saying yesterday i
don't think that's what she was saying i
certainly wouldn't say it my father was
a refugee to this country uh pretty
patel knows very well from coming from
her family came from
[Music]
uganda indian ugandans
that came during the time of uh idiom
and we know we know exactly what it is
like to flee persecution but i think
absolutely it's right also to say we
want a system that is uh fair but also
firm and rigorous because that is the
way you sustain public confidence in the
asylum and the immigration system more
broadly talk to me about what's
happening on the poland belarus border
given that you were previously um
foreign secretary of course um i believe
10 british soldiers military engineers
are on the border effectively doing a
recce there we've seen what's happening
to some of the people that are gathered
there they're in freezing conditions
people have died what should we be doing
well first of all it is absolutely
despicable that belarus and there is now
increasingly uh uh ever increasing
evidence that they're doing it in coups
with russia which uh i i've been saying
for a long time russia's questions to
answer are trying to use uh the the flux
of refugees and and economic migrants
that are coming uh uh through from the
mediterranean indeed north africa uh and
the middle east and trying to use that
as pressure on the european union and
europe as a whole we think that that is
totally outrageous and that's something
where we would stand in solidarity with
poland and our other european partners
in resisting
and that is utterly unacceptable it's in
violation of all the principles and
norms of international law and yet a
further demonstration of the outrageous
behavior of the lukashenko regime we
have also already as you'll know that
sanctions on the lukashenko regime i did
it as foreign secretary
the foreign secretary liz truss has
talked about what further actions will
take but standing up in solidarity with
our european partners particularly
poland and others who are on the front
line of that i think is critically
important
just before i let you go at least half
of our audience uh this morning from
today until the end of the year will be
working for nothing because of the equal
because of where we are with equal pay
women do not get paid the same as men
that figure is getting worse rather than
better it's been illegal since 1975 to
pay women less than men what we're going
to do about it well look uh if there's
any individual cases they should be
dealt with robustly by an employment
tribunal overall the gender pay gap has
been falling we've never gone but it's
bigger this year than it was last year
well well i we're over um 11.6 since
2010 it is certainly reduced and but
it's going in the wrong direction well
look at that then we need to solve that
and uh
where we need to look at the factors
underpinning it certainly if it is i
mean there are trends and ebbs and flows
in the workforce the pandemic would have
affected that um we we know particularly
women are on
uh part-time hours uh will be affected
by things like that but look
fundamentally take another 170 years for
women apparently as we are at the moment
to get the same pay as men well we've
done a whole range of things uh in
relation to more flexible hours in
relation to the toughening up the rules
uh around why is it not working then
well we we i think i think we have made
substantial progress but if there's data
which shows we need to do more that's
exactly what we'll look at good to talk
to you thank you very much good to talk
to you thank you
a very quick look at the weather if you
know it's cold
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
mild into the weekend it says i was
freezing rain and gales in the north at
times but sunday looks much colder at
the moment southern britain is rather
chilly under clearing skies while
northern and western parts are mild but
largely overcast there's some rain or
drizzle in places
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well within the last moment or two the
deputy prime minister dominic raab has
told us all members of parliament are
committed to overhauling rules for mp
standards i asked mr rob why the turnout
was so low during yesterday's vote on
standards
we've uh asked the committee on
standards to work up the detail but
around the principle that your
overriding priority must be serving your
constituents and therefore there must be
limits on external interests the
committee on standards will work that up
by january so it's not something that's
being put into the long grass so we're
tackling and fixing the problem at hand
but i think there's probably other
people that
thought that actually these were common
sense proposals very happy for them to
go through uh it was a late late-ish
vote um
i think it was around seven o'clock bit
later than that
now joined by the chair of the common
standards committee chris bright mr
bryant thank you for joining us on the
program this morning they are aware of
the problem and are going to great
lengths to fix it is what we've just
heard from the deputy prime minister
well i suppose you would say that
wouldn't he um
look the code of conduct needs to be
reviewed in every parliament and we need
to make sure that the rules that we have
are actually
enforceable
and of course what we've seen over the
last three weeks is the government sort
of deliberately trying to make it
impossible for a set of rules to be
enforced over paid lobbying in the case
of owen paterson um so i'm glad we got
over that moment but i'm slightly
worried now that what the government is
trying to do is sort of bounce everybody
into a set of proposals which have not
really been thought through very uh
properly my committee um is meeting next
tuesday we will consider all of these
matters and i and i hope that we'll be
able to produce a report very soon but
it won't just be on this one issue it'll
be on our suite of different issues that
we've been looking at for a whole year
and i think it's much better to look at
the whole code of uh conduct for mps
as one single unit rather than just
some immediate reaction to a crisis um
which was created by the prime minister
himself as he said and driving the car
into a ditch on a clear day
uh the prime minister was being
questioned by uh chair
chairs of all sorts of committees within
the house of commons i'm trying to keep
it as simple as possible for lay people
so a lot of senior politicians were
questioning the prime minister yesterday
there's a better way of putting it you
spoke to him having spoken to him did
you get the impression that he had or
had not read the report into owen
patterson
i don't think he read the report at all
and and uh i'm not entirely sure that
his account of events
um was was very honorable because he was
effectively throwing jacoby small and
the leader of the house of commons and
the uh government chief with mark
spencer under a bus
um saying that it was all their fault he
thought that they were cross party
agreement look um if we're going to have
a new code of conduct it's got to be
done on the basis of cross-party
consensus because it's got to stand the
test of time
and it's all very easy for one side or
another to come up with with some a
great idea and but you have to go
through the details so
just as a for instance there is a
suggestion at the moment that um the um
that you should limit the number of
hours an mp can spend on
non-parliamentary duties
well i don't know what counts as a
non-parliamentary duty does that include
knocking doors in an election for
instance or not i don't know which side
of the
of the equation that falls um
what what do you say about traveling
between your constituency in london is
that part of your parliamentary duty or
or not and and more importantly how on
earth would the commissioner ever
investigate whether somebody had spent
more hours than they should or they
shouldn't on their parliamentary duties
of course every mp
should throw themselves heart and soul
into the business of being an mp and i
think and that's what all of us do i
think i mean um my day i don't want
you won't feel sorry for me i know
because you start very very early in the
morning but um my day yesterday started
at six in the morning and i finished
work round about five minutes to
midnight last night and that is not
uncommon for mv's um so the the whole
idea that
which i think dominic rob was espousing
there and others were yesterday on
behalf of the government that it's going
to be very easy just to come up with
some plan in the next few days which
says um you can do so many hours doing
this and so many hours doing that it's
just
for the birds frankly
um starts at six o'clock in the morning
you've already missed an hour of the
early rundown by then i'm going to tell
neil patterson of you now let's talk
about owen patterson should we in a bit
more detail he broke the rules it has
been accepted by organizing a meeting
between the health minister and randox
doesn't seem to be any minutes available
for that meeting at the moment we're
told that there were meeting minutes but
they've now been lost and now we're
being told that potentially there
weren't any minutes at all
what are you going to do about that
well it's quite difficult to do anything
about an mp who is no longer an mp and
interestingly this particular part of
the owen patterson story was not part of
the investigation and that we did there
were 14 other meetings with other sets
of ministers and interest in
incidentally there was quite a lack of
understanding by government ministers as
to how the rules work on lobbying and
when an mp approaches them who's
approaching them on behalf of the paying
client and so we we may need to look at
that it seems to me on the face of it
extraordinary that there would not be
minutes written notes of a formal
meeting between a government minister
about a contract
with a a with a member of parliament and
the company concerned and when the the
mp and company concern had a um
you know
a paying relationship that just seems
extraordinary to me it seems
um that's a matter surely for the
minister of code how can you be a
minister
and not keep minutes of such meetings do
the ministers not understand the rules
of the house of commons let alone the
probity rules in government
very good point let me ask you this
before i let you go uh from today women
will be working for nothing to the end
of the year because uh equal pay is not
as it should be it was in law from 1975
as a result of what happened in dagenham
how can we still be in this position
it's preposterous it's outrageous it
makes me angry every week and
a lot of the changes that the government
has brought into taxation over the last
few years into benefits changes have hit
women worse than men one of the things i
would dearly love to introduce is free
child care universe free universal child
care for all regardless of wealth
because i think that would be the single
thing that would
release more women to be able to work it
would also incidentally i think improve
the quality of
um
child care in the country and on top of
that it will provide a a good career
path for a lot for a lot of people
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us
tomorrow's here thoughts tomorrow good
morning good morning kay well i think
the clear message we've got from chris
bryant there is that this sleaze row is
far from over because what mps voted for
last night is to try and set up a new
standard system that they will talk
about cross-party chris bryant's
standards committee that he chairs will
draw up proposals by the end of january
and that will help to find a solution
but first of all that vote only got
through
297 votes to zero which tells you that
opposition parties didn't vote at all
and quite a few conservatives because
there are 360 conservatives in total
didn't show up more than you'd expect
for a normal vote so it doesn't look
like there's much cross-party agreement
to be had there and also boris johnson
has said we must have reasonable limits
on the amount of time mps spend on
outside activities i think this is
triggered by the case of jeffrey cox the
barrister who has been in the virgin
islands working on a big case there and
not downing street uh tell us with his
constituents but how would chris bright
points out
his committee police that how would you
know if an mp was working on a train or
getting up at five in the morning and
even so they can't agree how many hours
is a reasonable amount of time even the
cabinet minister and mauricio valiant we
had on yesterday yesterday morning came
up with 10 hours 15 hours and 20 hours
as potentially reasonable amounts of
time so this is so fraught and it looks
like there is no real agreement in sight
certainly if they don't come to an
agreement by early next year then it all
has to start again with new ideas about
how to implement a new system tomorrow's
take at nine o'clock looking forward to
it thanks very much indeed it's equal
pay day but it doesn't feel very equal
the fawcett society says it will take
women the whole of 2021 to make the same
amount of money as men have made by
today's date the 18th of november let's
get more on this now should we from the
leader of the women's equality party
mandu reed hello to you thank you for
joining us on the programme how can it
still be so
i mean there's a couple of reasons for
this i think the first is that women are
disproportionately employed in
sectors of the economy that are under
appreciated undervalued and underpaid so
i'm talking about care workers child
care
workers as well as nurses for example
and when you look at the average
wage that a care worker takes home
you're talking around about around eight
pounds an hour whereas refuse collectors
overwhelmingly men in that profession
take home 11 pounds an hour so there's
that dimension to it but there's also
some deep structural stuff um we do not
have a situation in this country where
the contribution women make to the
economy the caring contribution paid or
unpaid is properly appreciated and we
could the good news is we can fix this
chris bryant alluded to one massive
thing and i'm so glad he said that
because we've been talking about this at
the women's equality party for the last
six years free universal child care
would transform our economy so would
proper shared parental leave so men and
women actually have a more even
distribution of care work in the home
but we also need to just toughen up the
rules and expectations on employers they
publish data which is fine but we need
to actually uh make sure that they
implement plans to close their gender
pay gaps and the last thing i want to
say on this is that
you know
women on average stop working from today
until the end of the year but if you're
a black woman or a disabled woman or a
woman from other minority groups that
period comes way earlier in the year so
there's a lot of work to do but it's
totally doable and i believe that it's
what's missing is political will
and also perhaps a political
misunderstanding when i spoke to the
deputy prime minister he said the gap
was getting um
narrower but of course it's not
he's confused about a lot of things
dominic rob he didn't understand what
misogyny was a few weeks ago and that to
be honest doesn't bode well we do need
people in government responsible for our
economy to properly understand these
things and and i think we are going to
find ourselves uh you know waiting a
very very very very long time for that
gap to close if uh the the government
and those in charge of all this stuff
remain uh uh you know in a state of
ignorance about the the real root causes
you know you mentioned earlier it was in
1975 that the equal pay act came through
another really interesting thing
happened in 1975 in iceland they had a
women's strike and that uh really put a
spotlight on the contribution women make
to the economy it really highlighted how
when women withdraw their labor the
whole of society grinds to a halt and
you know if we don't see changes on this
uh you know in in the near future i
think we may need to resort to measures
equivalent to what they did in iceland
because the political will needs to come
from somewhere
or the whole of car plants grind to a
halt which is what happened in dagenham
which is why we saw the equal pay act in
the first place now illegal of course to
play uh women less than men what
happened with a pandemic and furlough
what impact did that have on women's pay
i mean i think that is a contributory
factor to why we're in a situation where
all of the data is going um in the wrong
direction women were disproportionately
likely to
lose their jobs or leave their jobs so
that they could
take on the responsibilities of uh
providing care um in the home um in
london we know that 60
of job losses in london fell on women's
shoulders and so we need you know uh
politicians like the mayor of london to
acknowledge that and we can't have a
gender-neutral approach to how we
kickstart our economy we can't have a
gender-neutral approach to leveling up i
think if we truly want to level up
across the country we need to look at
how women have been impacted and
affected um and that would if we address
things from that perspective we would
boost prosperity in this country by a
significant margin which would benefit
everyone this isn't just about
benefiting women this is about
benefiting society as a whole and
kick-starting our economy breathing life
back into it and we can do that but as i
say it's about political will so i'm
urging that i'm urging the government to
re-look at this stuff and make sure that
uh as we go forward
the causes of the gender pay gap are
acknowledged and uh proper macro level
policies put in place to address it
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us thank you
now here's more evidence of the impact
of plastic waste on our natural world
look at this video footage has emerged
in florida of a bear walking through the
woods with a plastic tub oh there he is
over there stuck on his head
bless him you can't really see it in
that picture uh but we'll show you uh
it's apparently took four weeks before
the animal was spotted
by a conservationist there he is now
bless his cotton socks um as you can see
the group managed to pry the crack tub
off the bear exposing a noticeable deep
gash
oh
around his neck there he is
but
um they did nurse him back to health and
now he has been released back into the
wild
poor little chap
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
the north and west will have a rather
grey morning with fog and occasional
drizzle on the hills and heavier more
prolonged outbreaks over western
scotland elsewhere most places will be
dry and quite sunny it'll be very mild
but it will be windy especially in the
north northwest scotland will stay dull
and damp through the afternoon and the
northern isles will turn wet but other
northern and western parts will become
drier and a bit brighter the damp breezy
conditions mean air pollution levels
will stay low
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
talk about covered rules in wales should
we they're going to remain unchanged for
the next three weeks as record high
cases begin
falling let's speak to the welsh health
minister ellen morgan hello to you
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning um where are we as far as
covid is concerned in wales has wales
how's the vaccine going how concerned
are you about potentially having to
increase measures to stop people um
mingling integrating
so the good news is that they've come
down from some really high peaks of over
700 we're down to less than 500 now so
that's the good news and we're really
grateful to the welsh public for coming
with us on this journey and
really taking seriously the protection
measures that we've put in place
but obviously we are very concerned
because
the the winter is very much upon us
already uh hospitals and a huge stream
uh about 10
of the people in our hospitals at the
moment
are people in beds with covert and so
we're going to have to keep an eye on
that situation obviously as we enter the
winter months
but the good news is that our vaccine
program is going extremely well uh we
we've got uh significant numbers now
who've already had the booster vaccine
and we've got over 50 of our children 12
to 15 year olds who've been vaccinated
so uh people that have been really uh
really good at conforming with with our
rules in wales and we're really grateful
to them
okay our friends in northern ireland
from the 13th of december they have
decided that if you want to go into a
club or a bar or a restaurant you're
going to have to show a covid pass
that's quite controversial
how did people of wales feel about it
well we've already introduced the covert
pass into several settings including
nightclubs and
big events football stadiums for example
and recently from last monday we
extended that to
cinemas and theaters
what we haven't done this time which was
something which was a possibility is to
extend that into the hospitality setting
uh because those rates have come down
but we will be keeping an eye on the
situation keeping that
under review as we enter the christmas
period
but hopefully if if these rates continue
to fall uh then then we won't have to do
that uh we are concerned though about
the pressure on the nhs which is
genuinely very very intense at the
moment so where are you setting the bar
on whether you're going to introduce
those passes or not
as ever it's set in terms of whether the
nhs will become overwhelmed or become
under severe pressure uh we've got other
factors of course that are pushing the
nhs uh we're expecting a very intensive
flu period possibly uh but also they're
they're just people who perhaps
saved up their problems during the
pandemic and now they're coming forward
but it's really about focusing on the
covert impact on the nhs
but as i say already that's about 10 of
our hospital beds being taken up with
with covert patients as a result you
know that it's going to be significant
we know that pressure on the nhs in
england is going to be um almost
intolerable that's what we heard from
jonathan van tam earlier on in the week
so i suppose my question is why not just
introduce these covered passes now and
have done well as i said we have
introduced it so our uh our planner a in
the sectors that aren't represented so
far is i'm sorry mr clarify
it it is possible that that will happen
our plan a in wales is england's plan b
so we're still asking people to work
from home we're still insisting on
people wearing face coverings in in
public places like supermarkets uh so
so we're already have very strict
measures and every business has to do a
plan make a plan demonstrating how they
are tackling the the issues surrounding
kovid so
our measures are much tighter already
than they are in england uh none of us
want a christmas like we did last year
and so we'll keep an eye on that
situation but i think it was absolutely
right for us to say to the last public
look if if these rates don't come down
but they did come down i think it's
really important we respect that
quick thought on equal pay day if you
would please from today uh women working
generalization women working for nothing
men continue to get paid to the end of
the year despite it being illegal since
1975 and the gap is widening
it's just unbelievable in this day and
age that we're still talking about this
it's it's shocking that we still in this
situation we have to make sure that we
get women into prominent positions but
also to focus on those lower paid women
who are really giving their all in
particular for example in the care
sector we're really not respecting
people in the care sector i don't think
across the whole of the uk in the way we
should and we need to pay them a decent
wage and that's why in wales
we are looking at introducing the real
living wage for example for care workers
who are on the whole women
and just before i let you go i'm also
reading in this morning's newspaper
suggestions um that the travel industry
is saying we need to get rid of the day
two tests when people fly back into the
united kingdom they are completely
pointless and the rest of europe doesn't
have them do you have a view on that
well i'm very concerned that we're
taking away every measure that's been
introduced into in terms of the kind of
options that we have to just
monitor the the potential variants that
could undermine our whole vaccination
program so i am concerned that we're
going too quickly in terms of
dismantling the protections that we have
when people come from abroad so i i
think it's really important that we take
a whole view on this we've seen uh there
are no red list countries anymore uh
we've we're recognizing vaccinations
from from countries that where we
haven't done so before so there's lots
of measures being taken away and one of
the things is that the pcr test is the
only test where you can actually monitor
what are these new variants that may be
coming into our country so i just think
we have to be very cautious before we
dismantle those kind of things
understood it's good to talk to you
thank you very much indeed for your
expertise this morning thank you coming
up the government is expected to
announce that the eastern spur of the
hs2 rail link is to be scrapped what on
earth does that mean for the people of
the midlands and yorkshire stay tuned
for more on skype
[Music]